The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
We have talked in the last
class about magnetic trapping.
Today, I want to finish our
discussion on magnetic traps
with two demonstrations
of classical forms
of magnetic trapping.
But I told you that
magnetic trapping
is a purely
classical phenomenon.
The only quantum
mechanical aspect
is that this angle at which
the magnetic dipole is oriented
with the magnetic
field is quantized.
I also mentioned
to you, and this
was Wilks' Theorem, that
the total magnetic field can
have only local
minima, not maxima.
And therefore, we you can
do magnetic trapping only
for weak field seeking states.
These are states which
lower their energy
with photomagnetic fields.
And as a result,
since the spin is up,
the magnetic moment
is anti-parallel
to the magnetic
field, those states
can always lower their
energy by flipping the spin.
I know it's a simple
demonstration,
but, well, I can't bring
a real magnetic trap
into the classroom.
So what I have here, this is
just two little ring magnets,
refrigerator magnets.
And there is a tube.
So I just want to demonstrate
the one dimensional
form of magnetic
trapping to you.
And this is our atom.
It's in strong
magnet, elongated,
and it can be spin up
or it can be spin down.
So what you're seeing is now
you're seeing the two magnets.
And you're seeing
our dipole, our atom,
which is in a stable
trapping configuration.
And you can-- am I blocking it?
You can see that it's
stable by-- I just move it.
And you see how it
always comes back.
So that's one position.
I pull it over.
Here, you have a second position
where our magnet is trapped.
Here is a third one.
And here's a fourth one.
So there are four
positions where
we have one
dimensional trapping.
Well, this is one
for one orientation.
Now I take the magnet
and flip it over.
So we are changing now
in the laboratory frame.
The sign of the magnetic moment.
And there is actually
a very nice minimum.
You see how clearly
it is trapped.
There is one here in the middle.
I can also just show
you, it really stays put.
There's a weak restoring force.
And then here's number three.
So it seems very, very rich.
I've shown you seven
different minima
where trapping has happened.
And well, just to fill you
in, if this is our magnet,
these are ring magnets,
the magnetic field
is about something like that.
And if I plot the magnetic
field for this configuration,
I find indeed that
for one orientation,
there are four maxima.
So for one orientation--
just give me one second.
Yeah, there are four maxima
of the magnetic field
for this orientation.
And therefore, there
are four minima
of the trapping potential.
So maybe I should have
shown it like this.
There are one, two,
three, four minima.
And for the opposite
configuration,
there are one, two,
three trapping minima.
But now if you look, there are
one, two, three, four, five,
six ones marked in red, which
are for strong field seekers,
because these are maxima
at the magnetic field.
And there is only one
where the magnetic field
has a local minimum.
So in the last
part, I have shown
you the absolute value
of the magnetic field.
And you realize there are
one, two, three, four, five,
six maxima.
And this is responsible for
six trapping configurations.
And the seventh one was a
minimum of the magnetic field.
So in one dimension,
there is no problem.
In one dimension, I can
get a restoring force
for the strong and for
the weak field seeker
for any orientation of
the magnetic dipole.
But if we want to have a
three dimensional trap,
we have to look at the
three dimensional stability.
And it would be only
this one configuration,
which can be
stabilised in x and y.
What I've shown you
are symmetric fields.
So all these minima and
maxima only settle points.
They trap in one dimension.
But with suitable
radial magnetic field,
you could turn this one
here into a real three
dimensional trap.
But the other ones you cannot,
because this would violate
Wilks' Theorem.
I find it amazing that
this demonstration
has seven different magnetic
trapping configurations.
That's just how it
turns out to be.
Questions?
Collin.
AUDIENCE: So if you
look at the clover leaf
coil, the parts of the field
that sort of axial [INAUDIBLE]
provided by [INAUDIBLE],
those are the inner coils?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so if you
look at a clover leaf trap,
the pinch coils
create such a minimum,
which provides confinement
in the z direction.
But then you add a field, a
radially outward quadrupole
field, and that overcomes--
in this demonstration,
everything is
actually symmetric.
So this is a minimum
for this direction.
But if you would now plot it
as a function of x and y and z,
it would be a saddle point.
So this configuration
is trapping along z,
but anti-trapping along x and y.
But if you add a
quadrupole field,
a linear field which points
outward with these clover
leaves or the [INAUDIBLE]
bars, then they
would provide confinement,
which is stronger
than the anti-confinement
of the saddle point.
If you look at some equations
I showed you in the last class,
you will actually see
that in one of the slides,
I had the expression
for the magnetic field,
where you see how
the [INAUDIBLE] bars,
the radially linear
confinement overcomes
the anti-trapping feature
of the settle point.
Other question?
Then finally, let me give you a
demonstration for the following
effect.
I mentioned to you that
magnetic traps become unstable
when the magnetic
field is very low.
And I told you, well, at
very low magnetic field,
the energy difference
between spin up and spin down
is very small.
At zero magnetic
field, it becomes zero.
And then, the atom cannot
adiabatically stay in its MF
state, because we can violate
the adiabaticity condition.
So let me now show you
an example of purely
classical trapping.
And I think a number of you
now have seen the levitron toy.
Actually, a few years ago when
my group was one of the first
to use magnetic trapping,
in every single talk
I explained how
magnetic trap worked.
And I even showed this
demonstration live.
But in order to
demonstrate it really well,
I was building my own levitron.
I used machine parts.
I used the motor drive.
So I hope I can show you
one aspect of the levitron
demonstration, which
is usually not known.
So let me first give
you the punchline.
Magnetic trapping happens
with an orientation
of the magnetic dipole
which could always
lower its energy
by flipping over.
The reason why it
doesn't flip over-- well,
quantum mechanically,
it adiabatically
stays in a quantum
state-- but classically,
if we have angular momentum, it
is gyroscopically stabilized.
The dipole cannot flip over,
because it's a gyroscope.
It has angular momentum.
And actually, it also
has angular momentum
in quantum physics.
So the two explanations
sounded different
when I said stays
in a quantum state,
is gyroscopically stabilized.
But if you think
about it more deeply,
they have much more in common
than my language suggests.
So I think you know
how the levitron works.
You spin up the magnet.
And I had this nice
motor tool to spin it up.
And when you have
prepared the system.
Your atom has now-- atom in
quotes-- angular momentum
in the magnetic moment.
And you bring it to the position
where the three dimensional
magnetic field fulfills
the stability condition.
And you can now enjoy
magnetic trapping.
This is exactly what your
atoms do in your magnetic trap.
It is gyroscopically
stabilized magnetic levitation.
The only difference is that
gravity has to be compensated.
Gravity is a major player.
So the stability point
in the three dimensional
magnetic field configuration
includes the compensation
for gravity.
But I have to say, my group
was also at some point
trapping a Bose-Einstein
condensate in a few hertz
weak trap, where gravity was
the strongest force of all.
So what you have seen is
an exact demonstration
of the principle for
magnetic trapping.
But now comes my question.
What would you
expect, what would
happen to our magnetic trap when
we spin the levitron faster?
Does it help or does it hurt to
spin up the levitron, to spin
up the gyroscope, to
higher angular velocities?
So three possibility.
Nothing happens.
It doesn't matter
as long as it spins.
The second one, the trap
becomes more stable.
The third possibility,
the trap becomes unstable.
Do you want to
offer any opinion?
Collin.
AUDIENCE: Well, we have an
angular momentum, right,
of the really large omega.
When you apply
torque, it's going
to get torque
[INAUDIBLE], right.
It's going to be the
prefactor of omega.
So we have a giant omega, we
imagine that [INAUDIBLE] small,
[INAUDIBLE] torques.
No, no, no wait a second.
I did this the other way.
It was [? healing. ?]
Never mind.
PROFESSOR: So do we have
to do the experiment?
Maybe.
So now I put the motor
controller to full speed.
And I speed it up much faster.
You can hear the sound.
I really want to do
a careful experiment.
So we wait until everything
is quiet and has died out.
And now, we want to try if we
can can do magnetic trapping.
And you see it's impossible.
The system, when it
reaches the point where
magnetic trapping would
occur, it's unstable.
But then, well, just to
prove that it is only
the speed of rotation which
has caused the instability,
I just wait until
friction has slowed down
the angular velocity.
And now again, it
works perfectly.
So you see, if you rotate the
gyroscope too fast, it's bad.
It makes the magnetic
trap unstable.
Convinced?
How would you explain that?
If we have a gyro-- Collin?
AUDIENCE: Why aren't we working
in the limit where we assume
that the magnetic field
generated by our magnet
is sort of weak
compared to the trap.
So the magnet's really
modifying [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, we
assume here-- and I
can give you the
analysis-- but yes.
No, these are permanent magnets.
So the floating magnet is just,
you can say, a probe, a test
object which is put into
the permanent magnetic field
of the stronger magnets
of the stationary magnet.
AUDIENCE: Get an
additional torque
to-- because it gets
an additional force
into the upper state.
So it gets an additional
torque in towards the center.
PROFESSOR: It's not necessarily
the additional torque.
Let's put two things together,
it's really fascinating,
from different principles.
The first thing is
magnetic trapping
requires-- if you
have a magnetic trap
and you have an
inhomogeneous magnetic field.
And of course, you need an
inhomogeneous magnetic field,
the angle cosine theta
between the spinning dipole
and the magnetic field
should stay the same.
And this means
quantum mechanically,
we stay in the
same quantum state.
So therefore, a
magnetic trap only
works because the
rapidly precessing spin,
when the magnetic
field always precesses
around the magnetic field.
And when the
magnetic field tips,
the precession keeps the
dipole, the magnetic moment,
aligned with the magnetic field.
Now, what happens in a gyroscope
with a precession frequency
when you spin the
gyroscope faster?
We've seen that in your
classical mechanical
demonstration, if you had
the spinning gyroscope, which
was only [INAUDIBLE]
suspended with one rope.
And then it was precessing
in the Earth magnetic field.
Does this precession
frequency get faster or slower
when you spin the
gyroscope faster?
Pardon?
When the gyroscope
spins faster, what
happens to the
precession frequency?
AUDIENCE: Slower.
PROFESSOR: Slower.
Because the torque per unit
time adds some angular momentum.
This angular momentum adds to
the existing angular momentum.
But the more angular
momentum exists,
the smaller is the change.
And this lowers the precession.
I can give you another example.
If you rotate a coin.
When does the coin really
wobble very, very quickly?
Just when it has slowed
down and is about to fall.
And this rapid wobbling is
the precession frequency.
So the lower the gyroscopic
angular momentum is,
angular velocity is, the faster
is the precession frequency.
And fast precession is important
for adiabatic following.
So in other words, what you
saw here in this demonstration
was a classical analogy
for Majorana Flops.
Now, if we would translate from
our classical demonstration
to a real atom,
what feature, what
parameter characterizing
the atom, are we changing?
So when I spin
the magnet faster,
what would that correspond
to in atomic properties?
AUDIENCE: Higher mu.
PROFESSOR: Higher mu?
I'm not changing the
permanent magnetic moment
of the magnet by spinning
it faster-- higher
angular momentum.
But in this the equation, what
corresponds to higher angular
momentum?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
omega alpha,
the precession frequency
around the static beam field?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But what I mean-- so
the Larmor frequency,
this is a precision
frequency, becomes lower.
So what becomes lower
in the atomic property?
AUDIENCE: Sort of the
external magnetic--
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: h bar?
PROFESSOR: No, let's not
mess around with h bar here.
h bar is given by nature.
We can't change that.
But, I mean, OK.
Multiple choice.
B, no, no, no, no.
It's g.
Yeah, it's g.
So what you have seen is, you've
seen a demonstration where
in front of your eyes, I've
changed the atomic g factor.
And now you sort of see,
let me put it together.
What happens is, the
mechanical magnet
has a given magnetic moment.
And if I put much more
angular momentum into it,
it can sort of-- it has,
quantum mechanically,
speaking more
intermediate states.
Because it can change
its angular momentum
in steps of one.
So if I spin it faster, it has
many more intermediate states.
And each energy separation
has become smaller.
And smaller energy
separation means
I'm getting closer to degeneracy
where adiabaticity breaks down.
Anyway, think about it.
The analogy is really deep.
Questions?
OK.
So that's all I wanted to tell
you about magnetic trapping.
Collin.
AUDIENCE: When you increase
the angular momentum,
you don't necessarily change
the spacing between the levels,
though.
PROFESSOR: No.
The energy levels is when
the magnet is aligned,
it has an energy absolute
value of mu times b.
Here, it has minus absolute
And mu is simply the magnetic
moment of the permanent magnet.
So I go from here to there.
And the number of
energy levels in between
is the total angular
momentum divided by h bar.
So when I give it more angular
momentum, in one energy level,
in one transition, there is less
energy which will be released.
And it is actually, you
can say, the big note
between energy levels,
or the difference
which is a Larmor frequency.
So therefore, the precession,
quantum mechanically,
is the energy difference
between adjacent energy levels.
And if you give it
more angular momentum,
this energy difference
becomes smaller.
And this low precession
frequency, this small energy
difference, is bad
for adiabaticity.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does that have much
of an effect on f equals 1
and f equals 2?
Do you get more
[INAUDIBLE] if f equals 2?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
In f equals 2, we have
twice the magnetic movement
than in f equals 1.
But in f equals 2,
we have five levels.
In f equals 1, we
have three levels.
So the--
AUDIENCE: Is it that
significant of a difference?
PROFESSOR: So I think
it just cancels out.
The g factor-- I
showed you the formula.
What matters really
is the g factor.
And the g factor on
f equals 2 is 1/2.
In f equals minus
1, it's minus 1/2.
What happens is
the magnetic moment
in f equals 2 is larger,
because everything is stretched.
All angular momenta are aligned.
But the multiplicity--
you have five levels
versus three levels-- and
the two effects just cancel.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What breaks the system
when the magnet spinning gets
slower and slower.
Now we know why it destabilizes
when you spin it too fast.
But if you don't spin it at
all, it also floats, right?
PROFESSOR: OK, what
happens is yes.
If I stop spinning it,
it will no longer work.
So what we have is we have
a hierarchy of frequencies.
The fastest frequency has to
be the spinning frequency.
Then we have the
trapping frequency.
And the precession
frequency is one
over the spinning frequency.
So you want that the
precession frequency
is between spinning
and one over spinning,
because this is the precession.
And if you would
take the spinning
to lower and lower values, you
would violate that hierarchy.
Yes.
OK, evaporative cooling.
Evaporative cooling is a
powerful cooling scheme
to reach nanokelvin.
Actually, I forgot
to update this slide.
I wanted to say, this
is the only technique
so far to reach
quantum degeneracy
for bosons and fermions.
Very recently, people have
demonstrated laser cooling
of atomic strontium
to quantum degeneracy.
But if you read the paper,
it was laser cooling
aided not by
evaporative cooling,
but by collisional
distribution of atoms.
It's likely evaporation
where you evaporate into--
and you keep-- read the paper.
It's--
[LAUGHTER]
The scheme only worked
because collisions--
how to say-- you cooled one
region and another region
was cooled by collisions.
And this brings you
pretty much back
to further [INAUDIBLE]
evaporation.
Anyway, what I want to say
is there is a small footnote.
The field is evolving.
You can find now paper's
laser cooling to be easy.
But if you read the
paper carefully,
or if you talk to
me, I will tell you
that there were still
collisions necessary,
the same kind of
collisions which
drive the reparative cooling.
But before we go into an expert
discussion about variants
of evaporate cooling,
I should first
tell you what
evaporative cooling is.
But somebody raised his hand.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no I
just [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You wrote the paper
on [INAUDIBLE], for example,
that if your quantum
degeneracy [INAUDIBLE].
And that would be just
purely laser cooling, right?
PROFESSOR: Sub-recoil
cooling has not--
any form of laser cooling to
sub-recoil temperatures was not
compatible with high
atomic densities.
It only worked at
such low densities
that they stayed far away
from quantum degeneracy.
So nanokelvin, yes.
Temperature in the
nanokelvin range
his been reached
by laser cooling,
but not at sufficiently
high densities.
The densities, high
density, causes collisions.
Those collisions are
screwing up laser
cooling that it
doesn't work anymore.
And the only technique which can
reach nanokelvin temperatures
at sufficiently high density
is evaporative cooling.
And that applies to strontium.
Strontium was laser
cooled at low density,
and then the low temperature
was collisionally
transferred to high
density region.
So you can say, in a way,
it's an oddity of nature
that we are now using
quantum gases to reveal
new features of quantum
physics using ultra-cold atoms.
But the cooling
techniques which gets us
into the quantum
degenerate regime
is pretty much classical.
So this is a cartoon
picture how you
could think evaporative
cooling works.
You have a thermal distribution.
You remove the high energy tail
of the thermal distribution.
And then, you allow the
distribution to relax.
And it will relax to a
Boltzmann distribution, which
is a little bit shifted
towards the cold,
or the low energy, side
compared to the original dash
distribution.
And if you do it again
and again and again, you
wind up with a
distribution of atoms which
is colder and colder, because
every time you axe away
the high energy tail,
you remove atoms
which have, on average, more
than the average energy.
And therefore, the
average energy per atom
drops and drops and drops.
Of course, the atom
number also drops rapidly.
And I was only able
to draw it in this way
because I've been on-- I
think I-- actually, did
I. I forget what the
normalization here
is in the plot.
AUDIENCE: What is n?
PROFESSOR: n is a
number of steps.
So after 25 removals of the
high energy tail, I'm here.
And after 50, I have a very,
very narrow distribution.
So it tells you already
something very powerful,
which people were
not fully aware
before evaporative cooling
of atoms was invented,
that it doesn't take so long.
It doesn't take so many steps.
It takes 50
rethermalization steps.
And each rethermalization
takes two or three
elastic collisions.
So what this already
demonstrates,
if you can keep your
atoms and evaporatively
cool by removing the
high energy atom,
after a time which
corresponds to a few hundred
elastic collision times, just
a few hundred collisions,
you can go way down
in temperature.
So if you have this, I actually
used this cartoon picture
to write one of the-- to
develop a mathematical model
for evaporative cooling,
which is still the simplest
model for evaporative
cooling which
you can find in the literature.
So in any event,
but if you think
in that way, every
time you remove
a few percent of the
atoms, you realize
that you should think
in a logarithmic way.
Every time you lose a certain
percentage of your atoms,
you decrease the temperature
by a certain percentage.
So in the end, if you think
either in discrete steps
or continuously as
a function of time,
things should happen
exponentially.
So if you want to characterize
what happens into this system,
we should correlate
the percentage
of temperature change
to the percentage
of the change in number.
And here we have a coefficient.
And this coefficient
would give us
an exponential-- would
give us the power law, how
temperature and
number are related.
Or mathematically alpha, which
characterizes how much cooling
do you get for which
loss in the atom number
is the logarithmic derivative
of number with temperature.
All other quantities also scale
as power loss of the number.
Let me just assume we
are in a potential.
We have T dimensions.
So if you have an harmonic
oscillator, it's r square.
If you have a linear
trap, it's r to the one.
And for reasons
for simplicity, I
took d, the number
of dimensions, out.
So you choose delta
to get the 1d, 2d,
or whatever to get a harmonic
oscillator or linear potential.
OK, Because of equal
partition, the temperature,
which is a measure
for kinetic energy,
is equal to the
potential energy.
And the potential energy is
r to the power d over delta.
So therefore, the size
of the atoms in the trap
scales with temperature
with the power law.
But if the temperature
scales with the power law
over the number, then the volume
of the atoms, the temperature,
everything scales with
the number of atoms
to some exponent.
So everything is
sort of exponential
according to power laws.
So I mentioned already, the
volume and what I've shown here
is just the three
parameters which determine--
or the two parameters-- which
determine all exponential.
The volume goes with the
product of delta alpha.
The density goes with something.
The phase space density is
density over temperature
to the 3/2.
The collision rate
is n sigma v. So
everything scales
with n to the alpha.
And all the coefficients
are given here.
So the question
is, what is alpha?
So it seems delta is
our trapping potential.
Once we know alpha, we
have a clear prediction
what evaporative
cooling can do for us.
Well, alpha was,
remember, it told us
how much we lower
temperature or energy
when we lose a number of atoms.
So therefore, all we
have to figure out
is, when we evaporate
an atom, how much energy
does it take with it?
And therefore, alpha will
be determined by some people
call it the knife edge.
If you truncate the
trap at eta kt--
I showed you a cartoon
where I used the x
to chop off the tail of the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution
at 4kt.
So eta would have been 4.
So this is what we
control experimentally.
At what energy do we allow
atoms to leak out of the trap.
All right.
So if you set a threshold
of, let's say, 4kt,
4kt is the minimum energy
for atoms to leak out.
But some will be a
little bit faster.
In other words, they are
not creeping over the edge.
They are jumping, they
are zipping over the edge.
But because
everything is thermal,
this extra energy is on
the order of kt, or 1/2 kt.
And in the first analysis,
we can neglect it.
So in other words, we can
say that each atom, when
it escapes, takes away
the energy eta kt.
And eta is the
famous eta parameter,
which we determine
experimentally
when we evaporate.
Any questions so far?
Right now, I've pretty much
gone through definitions.
And now, I simply look
at energy conservation.
So now let's look at what
is the change of energy
during evaporation.
Well, for n atoms, this
is the kinetic energy.
And the extra potential energy
for harmonic oscillator,
it would be the same.
Equal partition for
another power law potential
that we have to introduce
as delta parameter, which
defines the power law of
the trapping potential.
So that means the following,
that originally, this
describes the number
of the total energy.
After an evaporation
step, delta N is negative.
I've lost some atoms
and delta T is negative.
I am now at a lower temperature
and a lower atom number.
And the difference is
simply the energy taken away
by the number of atoms
TN which have evaporated.
So with that, by
just rewriting that,
I get a result for
the alpha coefficient.
The alpha coefficient,
which tells
us what is the percentage
in temperature which--
how many percent
is the temperature
lowered when I lose
a certain percentage
of the number of atoms.
Actually, 1% drop of
the number of atoms
gives alpha percent in
change in temperature.
And this is the
alpha coefficient.
So I have an analytic
expression for that.
And sure, you realize
if you put your cut eta
not at high energy, if
you cut at lower energy,
than your alpha coefficient
can even turn negative.
Because then, the
atoms which evaporate
do not have more than
the average energy.
But actually, then
the model breaks down.
OK.
So alpha characterizes how much
more than the average energy
is removed by escaping atoms.
So [INAUDIBLE] are
very simple once we
know what is the threshold
of the trap, eta kt.
At what energy do
we leak out atoms?
We have a complete description
what is the energy, the phase
space density, and such
and such after we've
lost a number of atoms.
But you realize, at
least for all of you
who do the experiment,
something is missing here
that sounds almost too ideal.
We just evaporate.
And we can freely peek
what is the energy,
or what is the energy
threshold and such.
The experiment is
more constrained.
And we have to
work harder to get
into this good regime
of evaporation.
But let me introduce the
experimental constraint which
is very important by asking
the question how efficient can
evaporative cooling be?
So based on the
idealistic model,
which I've presented to you
so far, what is the highest
efficiency of evaporation
you can imagine?
Collin.
AUDIENCE: I guess in principle,
you could remove just one atom.
Then you'd save [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
You remove one atom.
You wait until you
have one atom, which
has pretty much all the
energy of the system.
One atom evaporates
and your whole system
is as cold as you
want to have it.
Of course, you are all
laughing because this
will take much longer
than the dwell time
of a graduate student at MIT.
In other words, what you
realize, time is a premium.
And it's not just the dwell
time of a graduate student.
It's not your patience.
What happens is in a real
experiment, there are losses.
There is some form
of technical heating.
Since you don't have
a perfect vacuum,
residual gas coalitions
cause losses.
And its clear you have a time
budget which is set by losses.
And either you evaporate
in this time budget,
or you've lost your
atoms for other reasons.
So that's now what
we want to bring in.
We can't make a realistic
model of evaporative cooling
without putting in the
constraint of time.
And the time constraint is
usually determined by losses,
by unavoidable atom losses.
So now we want to
understand what
is the speed of evaporation.
So we assume.
We truncate.
We remove an amount dT dN of
atoms above this threshold.
And then the question is,
how fast can we do it again?
How long does it
take for collisions
to replace the tail of the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution?
But now, you can make
an analytic model.
I was very pleased when I saw
that it is so easy to actually
get a precise analytic
model of that.
If either in the asymptotic
limit that eta is very high,
the number of collisions,
there is a certain number
of collisions which
replenish the tail.
And you want to know
how fast does it happen.
But now you can
use detail balance.
In an equilibrium
situation, those atoms
will collide live with the
bulk of the distribution.
And because they are in a
highly improbable state,
most of the outcomes
of the collision
will put those
energetic atoms back
into the bulk of the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution.
So therefore, the
number of particles
which arrive in this
tail in equilibrium
is identical to the
number of particles
which will leave this tail.
And so all we have
to do is we have
to calculate how many
such collisions happen.
This is an expression for
the fraction of atoms,
with the exponential
Boltzmann factor,
which you can find in this tail.
And those atoms collide
with a velocity,
which is not the
thermal velocity.
The velocity is larger
by square root eta,
because those are fast.
So by simply multiplying
the fraction of the atoms
with the collision rate, we find
how many atoms per unit time
are removed from this tail.
And in detail balance, it
means the same number of atoms
is replenished into the tail.
So if you now switch
to a continuous model
of evaporation,
where we constantly
evaporate the atoms
which are produced
through elastic collisions with
an energy larger than eta kt,
then this here is our
rate of evaporation.
Since we want to think in
terms of time constant,
this rate of
evaporation is described
by a time constant
for evaporation.
And this time constant
is now expressed here
by our experimental
control parameter eta.
Nancy.
AUDIENCE: So when we are saying
that the collisions are putting
atoms back into the
lower velocity states,
are we saying that the
collisions are more
defined than Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution?
So when you let the
system [INAUDIBLE],
it automatically goes into a new
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution,
and that's what
determines the tail.
But then we are saying that
the collisions are putting
the atoms on the table back
into the lower velocities.
So the collisions
are not [INAUDIBLE]
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution?
PROFESSOR: No.
We assume here that
the truncation is only
weakly perturbing the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution.
And at least the easiest
way to figure out
how many atoms are
produced per unit time,
if atoms in this truncated
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution
collide, they produce, with
a certain time constant,
atoms which will
populate the tail.
And I can estimate what is
this number of atoms which
are per unit time
fed into the tail
by assuming I do not have
a truncated Boltzmann
distribution.
I have a full
Boltzmann distribution.
And I simply calculate what
is the total elastic collision
rate of the atoms in this tail.
So in other words,
I want to know
how many atoms are
fed into the tail.
I get this number of collisions
by saying in detail balance,
this number of
collisions is the same
as the number of collisions
in the full Boltzmann
distribution which
goes backward.
And with that argument,
I can immediately
write down an
expression for what
is the collision rate which
produces high energy atoms.
Think about it.
It's subtle, but it's
fairly straightforward.
I make the assumption here
that eta is sufficiently large,
that I can use properties of the
equilibrium Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution to estimate
those eight constants.
And actually, when I found
the analytic expression,
I could compare to theory,
which was much more complicated
and used truncated
Boltzmann distribution.
And in the asymptotic
limit of large eta,
I was in full agreement
with the other results.
So yes, we have
an expression now
for the time constant
of evaporation,
how fast evaporation happens
because of elastic collisions
which populate the
high energy tail.
But usually, when you
have a time constant,
you want to express it
by another physical time.
And the physical time
which characterizes a gas
is the rate of elastic
collisions per atom in a gas.
So therefore, I want to express
the rate for evaporation.
The rate at which atoms are
produced in the high energy
tail is a ratio
lambda with the time
between elastic collisions.
And so we realize, of
course, that the atoms which
have enough energy
to evaporate are not
produced in every
elastic collisions.
Actually, there is an
exponential factor e
to the eta, because
it's only a small part
of those elastic
collisions which
happen which produces an high
energy atom which can escape.
OK, so with that, we
know how many atoms
we can lose by evaporation.
And this is our expression.
But now we have a complete
pretty realistic but wonderful
toy model to discuss all
aspects of evaporative cooling.
We have our control
parameter eta,
which sets the threshold at
which atoms can evaporate.
And this factor eta determines
the two relevant parameters--
alpha, which is the
efficiency of evaporation,
and lambda, which is the
speed of evaporation.
If we set eta very high,
following Collin's suggestion,
we can put it so high that one
lost atom, one evaporated atom,
can cool all the other atoms
to very low temperature.
But we know that this
would take too much time.
So in other words,
we have a compromise.
If you set eta very high,
each atom which evaporates
provides a lot of cooling power.
But high eta means we
have exponential slow down
in the evaporation rate.
And we have to wait
longer and longer,
or we never get into evaporation
because inelastic collisions
and losses has taken its effect.
So therefore, it seems
clear that this interplay
between efficiency and speed
is asking for compromise.
And this is what
we have to realize
in the experimental realization.
OK, there is one addition we
have to make to the model.
And this is the following.
We have to introduce
losses, losses
which do not come
from evaporation.
It can be losses due to
background gas collisions,
or losses due to
inelastic collisions.
So let me just show you
how I introduce that.
I mean, I told you
that everything
is the logarithmic derivative.
The logarithmic
change of any quantity
goes with the logarithmic
change in the atom
number times the coefficient.
And for reasons which
become clear in a moment,
I'm now not looking at the
temperature, or the density,
or the phase space density.
I'm really interested
in the collision rate,
because the collisions
rate is what
drives evaporative cooling.
As long as we have collisions,
the cooling can go on.
So I want to focus now on
how does the collision rate
change during evaporation.
And during evaporation,
what we are changing
is the number of atoms,
because we evaporated.
So by just putting everything
we have said together,
I have this expression.
I assume that the
number of atoms
changes as a function of
time with the rate at which
high energy atoms are produced.
The time constant for
this was lambda, the ratio
between the evaporation time
and the elastic collision time
times the elastic
collision time.
So this is just re-writing
what we have discussed so far.
But now I introduce that
there is another loss
rate due to inelastic collision,
technical problems and such,
which has a time
constant of tau loss.
And if I now do introduce
the famous ratio
of good to bad collisions,
good collisions
are elastic collisions
which drive evaporation.
Bad collisions are collisions
where atoms are just
lost due to technical reasons
and inelastic collisions.
So if I define this ratio
of good to bad collisions,
I have now this equation
here which tells me
how the collision rate
changes with time.
Just wondering, is a
dT missing here or not?
Yes.
So there should be a dT.
So this tells me
how the relative
or how the collision
rate changes
with the function of time.
But now remember,
since this is not
the derivative of
the collision rate,
it's the derivative
of the collision
rate over the collision rate.
It's a logarithmic derivative.
What we are talking here
about it, please add dT to it,
we're talking about is the
collision rate exponentially
growing when this
coefficient is positive.
Or is it exponentially
decaying when this coefficient
is negative?
So you realize that we
obtain a threshold condition
when this coefficient is
larger or smaller than zero.
And this is called the threshold
for runaway evaporation.
So let me just summarize
the physics of power loss.
The physics of exponential
increase and decrease
actually means that the
experimental situation is often
talking about a threshold.
If you're above threshold and
you get evaporative cooling
going, you have a
positive exponent.
And it will go faster,
and faster, and faster.
If this exponent
is negative, you
have slowed down evaporation,
you can evaporate a little bit.
But it will pretty much
come to a stand still.
So this is why quite often,
the experimental realization
of evaporative cooling
requires to put enough atoms
from the laser cooling stage
at sufficiently low temperature
into a magnetic trap that
you fulfill the threshold
condition for
runaway evaporation.
Any questions about that?
So in other words,
what we have found out,
we have found here an
expression for the threshold
of runaway evaporation.
And it tells us that
we need a minimum ratio
of good to bad collisions.
We may need 100
elastic collision
until we have one
inelastic collision.
And then our ratio is 100.
And we will see in a minute
if this ratio is 100,
if then we can make right
hand side in such a way
that we run away evaporation.
OK, so the left hand side is the
ratio of good to bad collisions
is maybe determined
how good our vacuum is.
What determines the
right hand side?
Well, we talked about it.
Delta is our trapping
potential, linear or quadratic.
Alpha and lambda depend
on the threshold eta.
How aggressive are we in
setting a threshold in energy
for the evaporating atoms?
And what I'm showing you
here is the condition.
I'm varying the threshold eta.
And now I'm figuring out what is
the-- if I vary the ratio eta,
I call this expression R min.
And my ratio of good
to bad collision
has to be better than that.
So if you just look at the
solid curve for parabolic trap,
this shows you that you
have to pick your parameter
eta between five and seven.
If you pick eta too fast,
evaporation is too slow.
And you need a much better
ratio of good to bad collisions.
In other words, you need a
better vacuum, for instance.
But if you put eta
too low, you're
not cooling enough,
because you're
cutting too deep into
the distribution.
You also realize that if
you take a linear power
law, like a quadrupole trap,
you get the dashed line.
And the dashed line
has a much lower ratio,
has a much lower value of R min.
In other words, if your
vacuum is not good enough
and you have losses,
in a linear trap,
you can still overcome
it by picking your eta
in this regime, whereas
for a parabolic trap,
you need at least
two or three times
better vacuum to get
into the runaway regime.
Anyway, this is how you
can look at those equations
and figure out what is needed
to get into evaporative cooling.
Collin.
AUDIENCE: Do you need to be in
the runway regime to get PEC?
PROFESSOR: Not necessarily.
Some early
experiments have done,
I think, the first
experiment of Eric Cornell,
I think they never
saw this speed up.
They had sort of
constant evaporation.
Maybe the cooling rate was
even slightly going down.
So you don't necessarily
need the exponential speedup.
But you have to be in a
regime where at least,
if you're not
gaining speed, you're
not losing too much speed.
But, yeah.
I mean, you can just
take the equations
and analyze them and
figure out if you're
in a favorable regime.
And ultimately, it's fairly easy
to integrate those equations
as a function of time and have
completely realistic models.
But what I presented to you
here is a simple analytic model.
And I used the criterion
for runaway evaporation
to discuss how do you have to
pick your truncation parameter,
and what happens if you have a
different trapping potential.
So based on those
models, you will find out
that if you truncated
an eta parameter of six,
every truncation of the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution
means about 1% loss
in the atom number.
And after 600 collisions, after
600 elastic collision times,
you have lowered the
atom number by 100.
But your phase space
density has increased
by six orders of magnitude.
And that means if you have
two orders of magnitude
in the number and get six orders
of magnitude in the phase space
density, then your gamma
factor, which I haven't really
defined it here,
but it's the factor
which tells you how the
phase space density increase.
Every order of
magnitude in the number
boosts the phase space density
by three orders of magnitude.
And that's regarded
as very favorable.
So in other words, we've talked
a lot about laser cooling.
In laser cooling, the standard
laser cooling schemes,
you're typically six
orders of magnitude away
form quantum degeneracy.
And this tells you how
evaporative cooling
can get you there.
You should expect to lose
approximately a number of 100
in the number of atoms.
And that's what
it takes you to go
from laser cooling to
quantum degeneracy.
And you can estimate
what your time
is by asking what is the
elastic collision rate
right after laser cooling.
If your elastic collision
rate is two seconds,
and you take 600
collisions to get to PEC,
you know that it would
take you 20 minutes.
And you better work on a vacuum
which has 20 minutes lifetime.
Or alternatively, you
improve your laser cooling.
Or you do some
adiabatic compression
in your magnetic
trap to make sure
that your elastic
collision time is faster,
that you can afford 600
collisions within the lifetime
given by other parameters.
Any questions?
OK, so evaporative cooling
happens in the everyday world.
If you have water and
you blow at the water,
the water evaporates.
And by evaporation,
the water gets colder.
So the water gets colder.
And it has, of
course, this process
has a lot of common to the
evaporative cooling of atoms
in an atom trap.
But I want to ask you
now why is evaporative
cooling more
dramatic with atoms?
We can get the
atoms really cold.
But I don't think you've ever
seen that you can blow at water
and the water freezes.
So what is the difference?
What is different in
evaporation how you encounter it
in every day life,
and evaporation
in the way how I just described
it, how we apply it to atoms?
AUDIENCE: Your control of eta.
Well, in atoms we can
really control eta.
But by blowing on it, it's
just one level we evaporate.
PROFESSOR: That's very close.
We can pick our eta.
But even more so,
what is constant?
Or what is the parameter which
describes evaporation in water?
AUDIENCE: Surface tension.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: The surface tension?
PROFESSOR: Some surface tension.
But the surface tension always
turns into a work function.
It tells us if we have water,
what is the energy, the work
function, for a water
molecule to escape?
And this work function,
it's an energy,
would correspond to eta kt.
If the water evaporates,
well, the work function
stays the same sort.
It's sort of electron, whatever
fraction of an electron volt
or whatever it is.
But the temperature gets lower.
And therefore, the number
of molecules which,
water molecules,
which can evaporate,
becomes exponentially smaller.
I mean, I've sort of lured you
into thinking that keeping eta
constant is the most
natural thing in the world.
Yes, it's the most
natural world for us
who want to-- efficient
evaporation of atoms.
But for normal substances,
it's the work function
which is constant.
So therefore, as
the system cools,
your eta becomes
larger and larger.
And everything turns
into a standstill.
So we are actively tuning the
work function of our system
to sustain a high
rate of evaporation.
How do we define eta?
How do we select the energy
threshold for evaporation?
Well, for many, many years,
Bose-Einstein condensation
was mainly done
in magnetic traps.
And there were two methods.
One is just lower
the magnetic fields.
But lowering the magnetic
fields is pretty bad,
because it weakens
the magnetic trap.
And if you weaken the trap,
you lower the density.
And therefore, just because
of that, the elastic collision
rate slows down.
So what turned out to be
by far the superior choice
is to remove atoms with
our F induced evaporation.
So if you have a magnetic
trap, you can tune in our F
spin flip transition
to a certain frequency.
But the frequency depends
on magnetic field.
The magnetic field in a
trap depends on position.
So what you're doing is,
you're selecting with your RF
frequency a certain
point in space
where the atoms
can leave the trap
and are transferred by a
spin flip RF transition
to an anti-trap state, and are
then rejected from the trap.
I mean, this is very flexible.
You can change the depths
of your magnetic trap
by just using an RF synthesizer.
And you can change
the trap depths.
You can lower the trap
depths without weakening
the confinement potential.
I don't have time
to go into details,
but what I'm showing
here is that there
is two regimes when you
have this magnetic trap.
Red is spin up,
blue is spin down.
And this is your RF transition.
There is a regime where
you have strong RF,
you should now use
dressed energy levels.
We've discussed dressed energy
levels in the optical domain.
These are now dressed energy
levels in the RF domain.
And there's a wonderful
chapter about it
in atom photon interaction.
So it really means
in the dressed energy
levels become
something like this.
So you have a potential which
looks like an inverted W.
And you really realize
this potential.
But when the RF is weak, you
have a certain probability
when the atoms go back and forth
through the transition region
that sometimes they will
fall down to the lower state.
And this looks more like this.
The diabatic picture
looks more like
that you have a little leak
and atoms are trickling down
to the non-confining state.
Anyway, there are two regimes.
And the experiment is
usually somewhere in between.
It is not necessary to go
to the fully adiabatic.
It doesn't pay off to go to
the fully adiabatic limit.
So this is how RF
evaporation is implemented.
But I should say in these
days, a lot of evaporation
is now done in optical traps.
And in optical traps,
the method of choice
is you just ramp down the
optical trapping potential.
Now, when you ramp down the
optical trapping potential,
addressing Collin's
question, you usually
do not go into the
runaway regime.
Because I haven't included
that my model assumed
we have a constant trap.
But if you now add to the
model that you are continuously
opening up, weakening
the trap, you
have another effect
which makes the exponent
for runaway evaporation
more and more negative.
And I think
ultimately, you don't
get any runaway
evaporation anymore.
On the other hand, optical
traps are often more tightly
confining than magnetic traps.
And you have sufficiently
high density to begin with.
So therefore, you can tolerate
a slow down of evaporation
and still reach the destination.
But anyway, I'm now
getting more and more
into technical aspects.
I think I've given
you the concepts.
But let me just flash
you one picture.
This of course, assumes
an idealized model
where we have only two
levels, spin up and spin down.
You all know that atoms
have hyperfine structure.
Sodium or barium has n equals 2.
And if you draw now
the stress levels
for five hyperfine
levels in RF transition,
it looks fairly complicated.
But the result is
fairly beautiful.
When an atom in F equals
2 reaches this point,
and in the dressed atom picture,
the point of evaporation,
the point where the atom
is in resonance with the RF
is the point where this
potential bends down.
The atom is adiabatically
transferred in a dressed state
from MF plus 2 to MF minus 2.
So when you evaporate
at this point,
without maybe you
noticing it, you actually
do a four photon transition
in the dressed atom picture.
Again, it's an
example where when
we teach about the
schemes, we can completely
neglect about
hyperfine structure.
And it's just wonderful to see
that the actual implementation
works as well for
complicated atoms
then it does for our
idealized two level atom.
Final remark.
What is the cooling limit
for evaporative cooling?
When we talked
about laser cooling,
I derived for you
the Doppler limit.
And we talked about even
improved cooling limits
when we discussed sub-Doppler
and sub-recoil cooling.
So what is the cooling limit
for evaporative cooling?
Well, the answer is there
is no fundamental limit.
There is no h bar or
quantized limit there.
There is a practical limit,
which usually depends
on residual heating, on
inelastic collisions,
and all that.
But we have reached
an evaporative cooling
temperatures as low
as 400 picokelvin.
And the limit was not set
by anything fundamental.
It was more set by our patience.
The lower the temperature, the
slower the process becomes.
And also, by the sensitivity
to technical noise
and technical perturbations.
Of course, just a
final comment which
is a segue to what we
hopefully do on Friday.
For evaporative
cooling, I've always
assumed that the energy
in the trap is continuous.
In other words, if you have an
harmonic oscillator trapping
potential, I've neglected
the discrete level structure.
And this is an
excellent approximation,
because many, many atom traps
have dressed frequencies
of a few hertz or kilohertz.
And at very low
temperature, even
at nanokelvin temperatures,
you populate many levels.
When it comes to the discrete
nature of trapping levels,
we should use a
quantum description
of the motion of
atoms in the trap.
And this is the regime
of sideband cooling.
Sideband cooling is
much more important
for ions, charged particles,
and for neutral atoms.
So therefore, we will discuss
sideband cooling on Friday
when we discuss ion traps.
Any questions about
evaporative cooling?
AUDIENCE: So may be
technical, but once you
get to the temperatures
of picokelvins,
how do you maintain--
do you keep
cooling to maintain
that temperature?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, usually when
we reach very low temperature,
there is some form
of technical heating.
And we've often seen
when we prepare cloud
at nanokelvin
temperature, we can only
keep it when we allow a little
bit of building evaporation.
We've sometimes seen
that when we just
keep the atoms in an atom
trap, they just slowly heat up.
But if you keep on evaporating
them at a very slow rate,
we can maintain low
temperatures for much longer.
Other questions?
OK.
So already pretty late.
We just have 10 or
15 minutes left.
I was hoping that
I could already
start earlier today to
talk about Bose gasses.
Today, I was hoping to talk
mainly about Bose gasses,
on Wednesday on Fermi gasses,
on Friday on ion traps.
We are sort of half an
hour behind schedule,
and I have to figure out
how I make up for it.
But let me just start
now with Bose gasses.
I've taught about this
subject several times
at summer schools.
And what I give you here is
a compressed version on it.
I will not talk too much
about the ideal Bose
gas, because most
of you have seen
that in statistical mechanics.
And I will also omit
superfluid hydrodynamics,
because well, it's
interesting, but it's
more special than
the other topics.
So what I want to cover
here is to give you
the main ingredients
for the description
of weekly interacting
homogeneous and inhomogeneous
Bose gases.
And then as a second
part, talk about
the superfluid
Mott-insulator transition.
But well, for those
of you who are not
working with ultra-cold Bose
gasses, maybe some of it
sounds like jargon to you.
But there is one sort of
overarching concept, which
I want to emphasize in the
theoretical description.
And this is some form of
mean field approximation.
When we go through the
weakly interacting Bose gas,
then we go through
superfluid Fermi gasses,
and we discuss the superfluid
Mott-insulator transition.
One theme will be if you have
a product of four operators,
and that's what you get when
you have interacting atoms,
you cannot solve anything.
And you need a method to go from
the product of four operators
to the product of two operators.
And then you solve a
quadratic equation.
And the step to go
from four to two
is called a mean
field approximation.
And I want to show you
three kinds of mean field
approximation, for
the one you have often
seen for the weakly interacting
Bose-Einstein condensate.
But then I want to show you
mean field approximation
for fermions, where it
is a pairing field which
is a mean field, not your
usual mean field energy.
And then I want to talk
about before that even, I
want to talk about the
superfluid Mott-insulator
transition, where we do a
very different mean field
approximation.
So maybe you'll
realize a little bit
by repeating that scheme
how theory is done
and how you can deal
with simple Hamiltonians,
but your can't solve
them because they
contain products
of four operators.
So there is sort
of a [INAUDIBLE]
through those three
chapters and sort
of showing you how you can
do interesting many body
physics by doing the
right approximation.
It also teaches you how
many body physics is done.
You have an Hamiltonian
which you can't solve.
And you have to guess the
solution and put half of it
in an approximation.
And once you've done
the right approximation,
the rest becomes [INAUDIBLE].
So with that spirit,
I want to go with you
through the Bogoliubov
approximation
for weakly interacting Bose gas.
I don't think I
have to say too much
about the ideal
Bose-Einstein condensate,
because it's dealt in pretty
much all undergraduate
or graduate text books.
There are just two
things to remember
in terms of a
system description.
First, whether
Bose-Einstein condensation
occurs or not depends on
the density of states.
And that depends on
dimension and confinement.
So the fact that
you are in a trap,
it changes the
density of states.
And it changes the criterion
for Bose-Einstein condensation.
But then in terms of
a system description,
if you want to describe your
Bose gas and its properties,
there are aspects of
Bose-Einstein condensation
which are pretty close
to the ideal gas,
and others which require
many body physics.
What is always close to the
ideal gas is the transition
temperature and the condensate
fraction, because what happens
is in almost all
experiments, when
you reach Bose-Einstein
condensation,
your gas is to a good
approximation non-interacting.
Because kt, the
transition temperature,
is much larger than the
interaction energy in the gas.
So before condensation, or
at the onset of condensation,
your gas is like an ideal gas.
And you will only find a
few percent corrections
to the formula
for the ideal gas.
So therefore, if you want
to know at what temperature
do you reach the
transition point,
or if you're below
the transition point,
if you're 50% below the
transition temperature, what
is your condensate
fraction, you can simply
look up the original
formula by Einstein.
And it gives you a
reasonably accurate answer.
However, for the condensed
gas, for the fraction
of atoms which are
both condensed,
those are atoms in
one quantum state.
For them, there
is no other scale
than the energy
between the atoms.
So therefore, for
the uncondensed gas,
you can get away with an
ideal gas approximation.
For the condensate
itself, we have
to put in the many body
physics of the interaction.
Well, this slide shows
here shadow images
of expanding
Bose-Einstein condensates.
We do evaporative cooling
in a magnetic trap.
You see the shadow picture
of the thermal cloud.
And you see the onset of
Bose-Einstein condensation
as the sudden appearance of, it
looks like, a pit in a cherry.
There is a cool down more
confined distribution
of atoms in the Bose
condensed state.
I think it should play again.
So this gas is
pretty much described
by an ideal gas
where you can put
in the g2 function, the
onset of quantum degeneracy.
But it looks almost
like an ideal gas,
whereas in an ideal gas,
the Bose-Einstein condensate
should be in the lowest
energy state of the trap.
And I will show you in the
next few minutes on Wednesday
that we are far away from that.
So interactions are negligible
for the normal component,
for the thermal cloud, but are
very important for the Bose
condensed gas.
So when you take cross sections
through this cloud, or 2-D
pictures, you see how the
broad thermal distribution
turns into a
Bose-Einstein condensate.
And if you look
at such a profile,
you can clearly see
the normal component.
The normal component can
be, with good accuracy,
be fitted by a
non-interacting model,
whereas central peak is a
Bose-Einstein condensate, which
requires the description
I want to show you now.
The condensate
fraction is shown here.
And again, with
fairly good accuracy,
it follows the
description of Einstein,
because the condensate
fraction is not
a property of the condensate.
1 minus the
condensate fraction is
a property of the thermal gas.
In the spirit of
Einstein, Einstein
calculated how many atoms can
be in the thermal component
at a given temperature.
So Einstein called
it the saturated gas.
At a given temperature,
you can only
keep in thermal equilibrium
a certain number
of atoms in your gas.
If you have more atoms, they
condense into the ground state.
This is sort of the
statistical description.
So therefore, what
I'm plotting here
is the condensate
fraction is actually
a property of the normal gas.
It shows that the
normal gas is saturated,
can only hold a certain
number of atoms,
and the remainder of
the number of atoms
has to be in the condensate.
AUDIENCE: I thought in
the three dimensional gas,
it was three halves.
PROFESSOR: Yes, but this
is an harmonic trap.
And the harmonic trap changes
the density of states.
Let's talk about the homogeneous
Bose-Einstein condensate
and weak interactions.
If you write down
the Hamiltonian
for the interactions, it
will appear many, many times.
The general way to
write down interactions
between two particles is
you annihilate particles
in momentum k and p.
And then, they reappear
at different momenta.
So one momentum
gets upshifted by q.
And one momentum gets
downshifted by q.
This guarantees
momentum conservation.
So what I'm showing you here
is the elementary process
of scattering two particles
with momentum k and p scatter,
disappear.
That's why we have the
annihilation operator.
And then they reappear
to a new momenta.
That's the most general form
of a binary interaction.
And now we have to
make approximations.
Nobody can solve
this Hamiltonian
in the most general way.
So one approximation we
make is that since the range
of the atomic interactions is
much smaller than the distance
between atoms or the thermal
[INAUDIBLE] wavelengths,
we approximate the potential
by a short range potential,
or delta function.
Well, the Fourier of a
delta function is constant.
And that would mean in
momentum space, this momentum
dependent matrix
element squared-- yeah,
matrix element--
is just constant.
So therefore, we can
approximate the Hamiltonian
by a constant
interaction parameter.
And then we have the sum over
all these creation annihilation
operators.
I don't want to go into details
of low energy scattering
physics, but it is most
convenient to describe
this parameter by u knot,
which is the Fourier
transform of the
interaction potential.
Or very often we parametrize
it with the s wave scattering
lengths, which is the
only relevant parameter
for elastic collisions
at low temperature.
So with that, we have
now a Hamiltonian
which has kinetic energy.
And here is the potential
energy due to the interaction
between the atoms.
And we have taken this constant
Fourier transform u knot out
of the summation.
Now, I mentioned already to
you that a product of four
operators cannot be solved.
You need an
approximation where you
reduce the number of
operators from four to two.
And then you solve a
quadratic equation.
And the solution is
Bogoliubov solution.
So how do we reduce
now this product
of four operators to two?
Well, when we have a condensate
where many, many, atoms are
in one quantum state, we
can make the Bogoliubov
approximation.
The Bogoliubov
approximation is, well,
if the creation annihilation
operator in the zero momentum
state for the condensate has
the following matrix element.
And now you can see,
if N knot, the number
of atoms in the
condensate is large,
well, we can neglect the
difference between N knot,
N knot plus 1, and
N knot minus 1.
And we simply make
the approximation
that the operator a
knot and a knot dagger
is replaced by the
square root of N knot.
And then, in this sum of
[? our quartic ?] terms,
we only keep those terms which
have at least two occurrences
of the index zero,
because the terms which
are for instance new
occurrence of the index zero
don't get this
multiplier N knot.
So we sort of do an expansion
in powers of N knot,
and we stop here.
So therefore, now if we make
sure that any combination
of those two involves the index
zero, we factor out N knot.
And then we have products
of k minus k with dagger,
dagger k minus k
annihilation operator, or we
have mixed term a dagger k, a of
k, a minus k dagger, a minus k.
But this is what we get.
The next step is
purely technical.
We want to get rid of N
knot and replace it by N.
So N is N knot plus the
sum of the population
or other momentum states.
And that's now our Hamiltonian,
which still looks complicated.
But it can immediately be
solved, because all it involves
is a quadratic
product of operators.
Let me finish this derivation.
It takes four to five minutes.
I don't think people
come in on Mondays.
They always come in
after us on Wednesday.
Is that correct?
So let me just continue.
I would like to reach the final
result with the Bogoliubov
transformation.
So what I want to show you
is that the moment you have
bilinear operators, all you
have to do is in essence
you have to solve a
quadratic equation.
And because with all the
indices and constant,
it looks a little
bit complicated.
But so let me just say that the
structure of this Hamiltonian
involves sums which are a of k
and a of minus k. k minus k is
of course important,
because that's
important for
momentum conservation.
So let me now call a of
k a, and a of minus k b.
Then this Hamiltonian has
the following structure.
It has terms a dagger a,
b dagger b, b dagger b.
But then it has other terms
a dagger b dagger plus ba.
Now, let me put it this way.
If that wouldn't exist,
we would be done.
Because an Hamiltonian
which has e knot a dagger
a is an harmonic
oscillator Hamiltonian.
It is diagonalized.
a and a dagger are
just eigenoperators,
which create quasi-particles
with energy e knot.
So if you could eliminate
this term, we would be done.
So therefore, let's
follow Bogoliubov
and say that we introduce
new operators, alpha beta.
And the alpha beta operators are
linear combinations of a and b.
Or vice versa, a and b
are linear combinations
of the new operators,
alpha beta.
And since we have
a bosonic system,
and we think it's a good idea
to keep the system bosonic,
we require that
those new operators
fulfill bosonic
commutation relations.
Those bosonic
commutation relations
are fulfilled if u square
minus v square, u and v
are the linear coefficient
which express ab
in terms of alpha and
beta if that is 1.
So in other words, u and v
are now two new parameters.
One condition for
u and v is used up
to ensure the bosonic
character of alpha and beta.
But now, we have a
second condition.
We can have two conditions
for two parameters.
So what we do is we just
rewrite this Hamiltonian
in terms of alpha beta.
And that's what we get.
It's a bilinear Hamiltonian
where the linear transformation
stays bilinear.
But now, our second condition
which we can impose on u and v
is that the prefactor of
this cross product is zero.
So then, by using
those two conditions
for u and v-- and you find the
equations in many textbooks.
I'm not discussing them
in great detail here.
We have obtained an
Hamiltonian of this kind.
And this is diagonalized.
We know now that alpha
beta create quasi-particles
at a certain energy.
So now, by going back,
I'm in alpha beta
where expressed by a and b.
A was a of k. b
was a of minus k.
I just go back to the
original nomenclature.
But we have diagonalized
the Hamiltonian.
So what we have achieved
now is our Hamiltonian
is written in this
following way.
Actually, I've recycled
a now. a is no longer
a particle in a
given momentum state.
It's now a quasi-particle.
So we have now diagonalized
the Hamiltonian
for the weakly
interacting Bose gas.
And what we have
obtained is, well, we
have the full solution.
Everything you want to know
about this system we know.
And in particular,
we know what are
the characteristic excitation
energies for quasi-particle.
And this quasi-particle
energy gives us
the energy as a
function of momentum
by replacing the
parameter u knot by c.
c is the speed of sound.
I can be rewrite it like this.
And you see that it
makes sense immediately,
because we have now a
dispersion relation, which
in the limit of high momenta is
just the normal kinetic energy.
So the quasi-particle
are free particles,
whereas at low momentum,
when this term dominates,
the dispersion
relation is linear.
And linear means
sound and phonons.
Bose-Einstein condensation
is a low energy phenomena.
So you should not expect that
you change any characteristics
of high energy quasi-particles.
If you wreck a particle in
the Bose-Einstein condensate
with high energy, it flies
out at a high energy particle.
But a low energy excitation
creates sound waves.
So this is what
we have found now.
And I will show you on
Wednesday how it is observed.